hey guys Ryan right here and Brady fries
here we're gonna watch the trailer today
for a little big movie it's called focus
focus
stars William Smith and Margot Robbie
Williams yes and Margot Robbie who's
gonna be the new Harley Quinn actually
oh yeah and she's great and wolf of
wallstreet kid hot
Veronica's not around right now so I
guess that's how the first trailer for
this it looked okay I haven't seen it at
all so much but yeah hopefully this
one's better what he's on to what first
of all you gotta wait till she gets my
pants off and then you got to give me a
chance to run and that's how you get the
money
he'd never dropped the car died was
d'lai and why'd you come up here
professional curiosity and I like boobs
figured it was a win-win lead you to
believe there's the earth-shattering
hump in the works
there's no earth-shattering hump in the
works yeah I don't even get thinly
veiled allure
you know what we make so much money we
are retired you see there's a science to
getting sexy maybe this is really fun
it's all about emotional connection what
makes you think you can trust don't get
you killed
I wouldn't trust him if I were you but I
should trust you
believe you right you can't believe I
like [ __ ] okay so rich for those what
you want to say because you're always
lying me and now we're dead
at the end of the day this is a game of
focus very confusing isn't it that's
what you get when you hire kind that
trailer was better than the first one I
said yeah it's much better than first
the first one just seemed like they were
trying to make a cool Kahn movie but it
wasn't really working this trailer
seemed to focus more on dynamics between
the team Margot Robbie and Will Smith
because the first time I saw a trailer
it seemed like it was really about the
con and then this thing starts happening
with them and it's it seemed so like
cliche this one the unique approach to
me about it is like the sexual chemistry
and the romantic chemistry between them
them too he's teaching her and then now
they're becoming ultimate con artists
together and it has more of a unique
vibe than yeah than what it did before
us for sure it looks sexy oh his voice
is so sounds like yeah he's pretty says
movies full of just sexiness oh and I
got I don't know his name but the guy he
was he was in uh
rodrigo santoro oh [ __ ] he's sexy he is
sexy he's like perfect when he was in
love actually ah yeah yeah yeah
underwear didn't get it [ __ ] the redhead
though no no unfortunately I like con
movies in general yeah I think they're
awesome like Ocean's eleven I have I
always have a blast when I watch I think
a cool calm movie that's actually more
about the romantic chemistry I think
that'd be a blast to watch actually that
sounds like that it seems to be like the
main part of the plot yes he's according
to this trailer yeah I hope so that he
was he was narrating cuz I'll be honest
this script doesn't look all that
different to me what I think will really
carry this movie are their performances
they're both fantastic actors you know
Will Smith has always has really come a
long way since Fresh Prince of bel-air
that's the last thing I saw from that
guy so this is really surprising to me
you know like they're both hot and sexy
and I know you got like white chocolate
dark chocolate thing going on which is
[ __ ] hot so it's hard to see that
getting mixed up she like at the bigger
[ __ ] I do that accent like at the khaki
I like movies in general work there's a
professional and the one being trained I
always enjoy them really yeah obviously
it's fun to watch it as then you're like
maybe I can be a student one day yeah I
lost my movies do that yeah I want to be
a thief and it's kind of cool to see
Will Smith planes I can't really think
of a movie where he is this pretty much
as an antihero because he's a thief
right that's true you know I guess so
it is interesting yeah I don't recall
ever seeing him actually play like the
antihero role why does it call focus
who's gotta pay attention and focus on
or to get the job ever but I thought
their logo kind of look like the Focus
Features almost I was like oh well the
focus feature films no wait that's not
it that's just the name of the movie if
this movie has the tone and vibe that
this trailer was portraying it just
seems like it would be a cool film oh my
god like just a cool stylish sexy film
so yeah if it has that then I'm all I'm
on board and a soundtrack was so good
exactly like if it has a soundtrack like
that anyway guys thanks for telling me
that trailer was out if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects and brandy has a channel
too it's always more interesting if you
make it look like there's something
going on
brandy has a channel too she doesn't
move your reviews you can subscribe to
the real rejects and then her channel so
subscribe to Brandy's Channel Louie
Kemboi you should make a shout-out
Twitter we have a shout out Facebook
facebook.com slash the real reject shout
outs
I love how a lot of people still aren't
going there and these in a comment
saying I should put it on a different
social network and you shout on your
next video for all the guys that thinks
samantha is superhot okay Sean Sully you
know that is nope it's Scully Scully is
from x-files yeah so Leigh is friendly
slowly yes related he's related to him I
could see it yeah I mean Shawn is he's
he's the evil skinny twin that's based
on a real character they wouldn't like
scare people they would kidnap them and
then sell them into slavery grades oh
yeah I'm a big fan of dark humor no no I
think we haven't covered the children
slave trade Terry why no those are a
horrible thing Shawn cut it out Shawn
you're being a dick don't ever do that
again ever trade a child
Sully unless it's your own and you can
get a better child then trade it my kid
is a piece of crap I'm Italian adopt
another one and then let my kid know
that even though it's my biological
child my adopted trial is way better
yeah to prove a point
those Sully if you're planning on
[ __ ] kidnapping kids I'd say stop and
just trade your own for a better one or
enough one to make your one feel like
[ __ ] these are the rules on how to make
children feel horrible
you really gotta focus